- [Recording] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [William] Good afternoon everyone and
thank you to the organizers here of CARTA
for inviting me to participate and thank
all of you, a great crowd, for coming out
to see this fascinating topic explored. I
tend sometimes to be accused of nihilism
with regard to the origin of Homo because
my view is we actually know nothing about
the origin of Homo, just saying. And the
reason is simple in my view; is that while
it is true that we have a pretty good
fossil record of the genus Homo, the Homo
lineage as Bernard just finished
explaining, by around 2 million years ago
with some diversity and different adaptive
packages in different species: erectus,
habilis, rudolfensis. On the assumption
that these three forms shared a common
ancestor at some point. That common
ancestor lived older than 2 million years
ago in a period of time in which we have
not a fender and a tire and a piece of
gear shift, but in which we have a
fragment of tire thread, which we have a
fragment of a headlight. And we are trying
to reconstruct an evolutionary history of
a group for which we basically have a car
wreck. And this is what we have to solve,
this is the problem we have to solve and
this comes from field work and I'm going
to illustrate for you today in my view
where I think the genus, the Homo lineage
arose and where we have to re-double our
efforts for increasing the representation
of this lineage older than 2 million years
ago. Now, as Bernard ably suggested, the
modern history of the study of the
evolution of the genus Homo really begins
with Louis Leakey and colleagues and the
recognition of the species, Homo habilis
in 1964 based on material from Bed I in
Olduvai Gorge dated to between around 1.7
and 1.75 million years, they discerned in
the type specimen of the species older by
Hominid VII what they thought was a
human-like dexterous ability in the hands,
they discerned a notable increase in
endocranial volume, brain size, in
relation to then known Australopithecus
species, mostly from southern Africa and a
reduction in tooth size which they saw as
emblematic of an overall gracilization of
the chewing apparatus in almost a
human-like arrangement. And putting these
three characteristics together with the
plentiful stone tools that had been
recovered for years in these sediments,
they arrived at the conclusion that this
species, habilis, belonged near the base
of the genus Homo. So convinced were they
of this conclusion that Philip Tobias, one
the co-authors of the species, was able to
write in 1965 that Homo habilis
represented that last remaining major gap
in the pleistocene evolution of the genus
Homo, "of the story of human evolution, "
to quote him directly. And in this
phylogeny shown here from one of Tobias'
papers, you can see the genus Homo is
represented as a single, gradually
evolving line characterized by uniquely
human characteristics related to large
brain size, reduced canine teeth, a
perfection of bipedal locomotion as we now
see it, a slowing down of the growth
trajectory, technology, language and so
forth. This was a package of
characteristics seen in modern humans and
thought to go back in time to at least 2
million years as an integrated whole,
along this slowly emerging lineage
culminating in Homo sapiens. The problem
was of course is that older than 2
millions years ago, there was virtually no
fossil record that could be confidently
associated uniquely with our lineage. And
so whether these characteristics emerged
piecemeal, step-wise and therefore each
demanding a separate explanation for
origin, or whether they emerged as a
package together, where one explanation
would take care of them all, could not be
discerned. Now a lot has happened, as
Bernard has pointed out in the years since
early 1960s. And beginning in the 1980s,
in large part due to the work that he and
others have done in those years, we now
see the genus Homo as a much more
complicated array of species. In my view,
there are at least three broadly
contemporaneous forms present at around 2
million years ago whereas in 1964, the
Leakeys would have said there's one in the
genus Homo: Homo rudolfensis, Homo habilis
and Homo erectus. And one of the lessons
that we have learned from the appreciation
of greater diversity in our own genus at
this period of time, is the idea that
there is not one adaptive package that can
describe them all, but there are perhaps
multiple ones. And the question is which,
if any, are germane to the origin of the
lineage itself? Or, are they all, in one
form or another, subsequent developments
to the establishment of the lineage?
Following on Bernard's talking about
Toyotas and clades, my appreciation, my
rendering of the information available
from these three forms between around 1.7
and 2 million years ago is that they do,
in fact, constitute a monophyletic group.
This is not the place to go into a
detailed rendition about the evidence for
it, but I think it speaks fairly clearly
to the idea that these three at 2 million
did in fact share a single unified
ancestry predating that time period,
moving back towards the 3 million year
mark. And the question is, where is it?
And who was it? And here's where we run up
against a roadblock. Now, why is this
important more than just for the purposes
of putting cladograms or phylogenies on
the page is because in the last decade or
two, information from global climate
change, paleo-climatic change, has made it
clear that the tim period in which many
people suspect the Homo lineage arose was
one of a very widespread, impactful change
in global climate, creating an expansion
of ice sheets, reduction in sea levels,
drying out of the African interior. And
that time period has been focused right
after the 3 million year mark; 2.8, 2.7
and so forth. And that drying out of
Africa has been seen as motive in the
origin of the robust Australopithecines,
the origin of the genus Homo, even to
stone tool manufacture. This has become
the prevailing hypothesis that the
complexification, if you will, of hominids
and the origin of technology is all
associated with the local impacts of these
global changes. The problem is that
there's no fossil evidence for the genus
Homo that is informative on exactly what
those changes were at this particular
point in time. We do have of course
Oldowan tools at around 2.6 million. And
as Bernard and others have pointed out,
perhaps that is a proxy for the genus Homo
or maybe it isn't. It's not outside the
realm of possibility given what we know
about how chimpanzees can make tools that
some Australopithecus is capable of making
them, too. So, questions and an absence of
evidence. And here is the sum total of the
fossil record of the genus Homo between 2-
and 2.5 million years ago. It would fit in
a shoe box and leave room for a decent
pair of shoes. All of these fossils have
been promoted by one person or another,
one group or another as identifying the
genus Homo older than 2.0 million years
ago and all of them have been doubted. And
I'm not going to go through them here to
point out the weaknesses and strengths of
the various arguments, other than to say
that the very fact that there's debate can
be traced to the fact that there's
relatively little evidence. And this is
why groups return to Africa, go to the
field to African sites, in East Africa, in
South Africa all the time focusing on this
time period which, in my view, is one of
the most intriguing of all the time
periods in human evolution to increase our
understanding of the fossil record. One
area where the group from The Institute of
Human Origins which I direct at ASU has
been focusing on, of course, for years is
Ethiopia. We've worked at the Lucy site
more or less continuously since 1990. And
colleagues of mine, Dr. Kaye Reed at ASU
and Chris Campisano and others, have
expanded the work, the IHO work in
Ethiopia, to a place called Ledi-Geraru as
seen here as slightly north and east of
the Hadar area. What attracted them to
this area? Two things, knowledge that the
environments represented by the sediments
in this area looked different from those
that were very common and well-understood
in the Lucy time period, older than 3
million, some 20, 30 kilometers away at
Hadar. And second, the suspicion verified
since then that the rocks may actually
represent a slightly younger time period
and that's important because at Hadar, as
you will see, we have Lucy species,
Australopithecus afarensis up to about 3
million years and then we jump across
three quarters of a million years and we
have a jaw of Homo with some stone tools
at 2.3 million. Lucy, Homo; older,
younger. Gap in the middle, let's try to
fill it. And that was their mission. Now,
in the lower Awash Valley, these areas
around Hadar and middle Ledi and Gona and
Dikika and Woranso-Mille, there are
excellent sediments going backwards in
time from around 3 million years ago. And
we have an excellent set of sediments in
places like Gona and Hadar that take us
forward from around 2.5 million years ago.
It is the time period in between that is
critical and is germane to the questions
about where the three forms of Homo that
we know of at 2 million perhaps emerged
from? And these sediments are present
amply, now well-studied in the Ledi-Geraru
area spanning in time from around 2.8
million years to about 2.6 million years.
And what's really important to understand
about these sediments, and this is both an
advantage and a disadvantage is that they
are not continuous across time, but
instead are exposed in fault blocks,
adjacent fault blocks which means that
each block of sediment is a unified slice
of time separated from another block next
to it which has itself a unified period of
time with slight gaps in between them.
Disadvantaged because we can't trace
evolutionary events continuously but
advantage because fossils that come,
demonstrably come, from particular fault
blocks can be narrowed to a very narrow
range of environments and associations
with other animal species, etc. So, a plus
and a minus. And here is the Ledi-Geraru
area. Kaye and her team have been working
her for more than a decade before they
found their first hominid. Looking at the
fauna, looking at the geology, trying to
understand the environments. And by the
way, this is an area called the Lee Adoyta
basin and you can see here, here's one
fault block, here's another fault block,
and here's a third fault block. They're
about three or four fault blocks just
exposed in this one view, very clearly
delineated. You can see one of the faults
running right through here. Now, back in
2013, Kaye and her group of
paleontologists were surveying an area in
the Lee Adoyta basin called the Gurumaha
block just in the one fault block. And at
the base of this one hillside, there's a
volcanic ash that is now well-dated, very
precisely dated to 2.8 to 2, plus or minus
a handful of years, in the million year
range. And on one winter's day, one of our
graduate students at ASU, Chalachew
Seyoum, was surveying up on this hillside
and found this little jaw. That jaw eroded
out of this hill, perhaps in a recent rain
storm and resides about 10, maybe 12
meters above that volcanic ash. And on the
hillside, there are no sediments up above
younger that the jaw could have floated
down from. It eroded out of that hillside
and it's around 10 meters above the tough.
So here's the jaw after it has been
cleaned up. And I'm here to tell you that
it answers some questions, answer some
very specific questions. It doesn't answer
all the questions. But there's a myth out
here in Paleoanthropology that unless you
have a complete skeleton, you're not
prepared to answer any meaningful
questions and I wish to dispel that myth.
You know, since Raymond Dart named
Australopithecus in 1925, there have been
a plethora of hominid species named,
recognized; Australopithecus africanus,
Paranthropus robustus, Paranthropus
boisei, Homo Habilis, on and on. Many of
them, if not most of them on the basis of
material that we here today would
consider, at best, imperfect. A fragment
of a jaw, a bit of a brain case, some
teeth, and the fact of the matter is is
that in the intervening years, the vast
majority of those species recognized on
the basis of imperfect material have been
verified as to be meaningful evolutionary
units. We are not at sea when we have
small fragments. We are limited in the
type of questions we can ask. If complete
skeletons were the answer to all of our
questions, then Lucy would have settled,
once and for all, the debate about when
early humans made a commitment to
terrestrial bipedality. Instead, she
generated what is now going on to five
decades of debate about that question. It
depends on the question and this question,
the question that we address to this jaw,
is it the same thing as Australopithecus
at 2.8 million or is it something
different? And I engaged in that question
with my former PhD student, Brian Brian
Villmoar now at University of Nevada, Las
Vegas, and Chalachew Seyoum our graduate
student who found the jaw. And we came to
the conclusion that in many respects, it
differs from your standard issue
generalized Australopithecus jaw. Seen
here on the left is a nice jaw of Lucy's
species, Australopithecus afarensis and on
the right is a reconstructed from a scan
of the specimen from Ledi-Geraru. We
noticed that the jaw differs
rather...these two jaws differ rather
remarkably. The afarensis jaw is typically
long and narrow with fat molar teeth,
primitive pre-molars and so forth. And our
major comparison was to something like
this, one of the jaws from the Dmanisi
site dated to about 1.8 million years
which is attributed to Homo erectus. And
there's a much greater similarity in the
shape of the dental arch, in the form of
the teeth, the pre-molars being
symmetrical and so forth, to this 1.8
million year old Homo erectus jaw than to
Lucy's species. And it extends also to the
architecture of the jaw and I'm not going
to go into the details here, but
underneath the pre-molar, the afarensis
jaw is characterized by a highly sculpted
out, contour like a chimpanzee probably
due to the very large canine teeth absent
in the Ledi-Geraru jaw. The back part of
the mandible where the vertical part
called the ascending ramus arises from the
body of the jaw is located in the Ledi jaw
well back of the third molar, not forward
as it is in Lucy's species over the second
molar. And the upper and lower boundaries
of the mandibular borders beneath the
teeth and at the base are more or less
parallel. And in Australopithecus, they're
not, it gets shallower to the rear. And by
the way, it's also true of
Australopithecus africanus which is
slightly closer in age to the Ledi jaw in
South Africa, the same kind of thing. So,
when we made the comparison to jaws of the
genus Homo, later in time obviously
because we don't have much in the 2.5 to 3
million year period, the similarities were
very apparent to us. This is a jaw that
exhibits characteristics that forecast
anatomy that is common, the most common
anatomical patterns in jaws of the genus
Homo younger than 2 million. So we
published it, in not quite a year ago, in
the Journal of Science as a 2.8 million
year old jaw of the genus Homo. Now does
it answer questions about what were the
adaptive packages present early on in the
lineage leading to us? Of course. But what
it does do is that it puts one data point
in an area that is otherwise a void in the
evolution of our own genus. Question is
what kind of environment did it live in?
Did it live in a dry environment? Did it
live in an open one? Germane to the
questions about what drove early evolution
of Homo. And data that's been put together
by Kaye Reed and given to me for this
purpose shows that this jaw is found in a
context of animal species that lived in
essentially grassland environments, very
different in terms of how open or closed
the habitats were compared to time periods
in which Lucy's species lived. And this is
just a couple hundred thousand years
later. Now, I hasten to add here, I am not
asserting that the origin of the genus
Homo is due to a drying out of the
environment. But one thing we can say,
because of the very confined time period
of the Gurumaha fault block in which the
mandible and the fauna on which this
inference is made, suggest that the modal
environmental signal at 2.8 in this area
is one essentially of a grassland
environment. And we can see that by
looking at some of the other animal
fossils that have been found associated
with the horizon from which that mandible
has come. This is the Gurumaha block,
these are El Salafin bovid frequencies and
the horse frequencies, both of which of
course are well-known grazers. And
together, in the Gurumaha block, they
constitute nearly 40% of the macrofauna,
excludes elephants and hippos and stuff.
I'm not saying it's dry, we're saying it's
open. So it's 40% of the macrofauna and
that is very impressive compared to the
frequencies back in Lucy's time starting
just 200,000 years earlier. Opens up areas
for inquiry. And finally, some new data
coming out of Kenya from Sonia Harmand's
group suggests that stone tool use, in
fact, began not with the genus Homo,
maybe. But perhaps as long ago as 3.5
million years when we have
Australopithecus. And if these finds are
verified, it opens up a whole new range of
possibilities looking at the adaptive
packages that constitute the ancestral
platform from which the genus Homo
emerged. And so to finish up, here we have
Ledi-Geraru, here we have our formerly
first appearance, a former first
appearance of stone tools now pushed back
here perhaps and does that imply that the
genus Homo itself has even an earlier
origin than we think of at 2.8, perhaps
back as far as Lucy? Or could Lucy herself
have been the first stone tool maker?
Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪